good afternoon we start with breaking
news that the foreign office has
confirmed one british national has been
killed in ukraine and another is missing
in the last hour i spoke to skies
security and defense editor deborah
haynes who has more information
yes um so there is some news from the
foreign office that have just confirmed
that a british national has been killed
in ukraine um and they are providing
support to the family
and a second british national is
believed to be missing in ukraine and
again the foreign office saying that
they are providing support to that
person's family
and uh urgently seeking further
information um now i believe it's
thought that these two men
had been in ukraine as volunteers
helping to
support the ukrainian forces in their
fight
against russia that's not
confirmed
but that is what is thought that they
were doing here the foreign office
hasn't provided any further details um
on the two men um other than to confirm
that one british national has been
killed in ukraine and a second british
national is missing in ukraine and that
the foreign office is urgently seeking
further information um i've spoken to uh
we've spoken
a colleague of mine spoken to
the international brigade spokesperson
out here and they're not providing
any information at the moment um
obviously
there are a number of foreign foreigners
who've decided to come to ukraine um
many of them ex-military for example
from the uk there's been
british veterans who've chosen to come
out here and join the fight you'll
remember at the beginning of the war
ukraine's government urged and asked for
volunteers from across the world to come
to ukraine and help support ukraine's
armed forces
as they combat russia's invasion of
course the advice from the uk government
is absolutely to um you know to say that
people shouldn't be coming to ukraine to
fight and they can support ukraine and
in many other ways but
a number of individuals decided to come
anyway and are in the country um helping
uh ukraine's military fight and we've
seen those two individuals that were
captured uh by russian forces um and
have been shown on television in recent
days again underlining the risk that
people take when they do come here as
foreign fighters to or foreign
volunteers to join the fight but yes the
information that we're receiving um just
now from the foreign office
is this news that um a british national
has been killed in ukraine a second
british national is missing in ukraine
and the foreign office is urgently
seeking further information on um what's
happened to him um and and for now
that's that's all the information that
we're able to to broadcast